We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
This is a really funny voicemail.
See if you can pick up on what's funny about
it.
Take a listen.
I was just wondering, are you from Father
Moton and First Amendment right?
Not for office.
Yeah.
This is so funny.
So the 25th Amendment provides a mechanism
for removing Donald Trump or any president
for being unfit, hilariously.
The caller mentions the 21st amendment, which
ended prohibition, which was put in place
by the 18th Amendment.
So I know I'm sort of kidding around.
I know the caller means the 25th Amendment,
but I actually started thinking, is there
any way we could use the 21st Amendment to
justify removing Donald Trump?
I can't think offhand of how he would do it.
But a funny idea, but no, it is the 25th Amendment
that could be used.
It will not be used.
Donald Trump's cabinet has no interest in
removing him, no matter how clearly unfit
for office he is.
We will have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about whether it is fair to blame
college parties for the spread of coronavirus
or not.
We will also talk about Second Amendment sanctuary
cities.
You may or may not have heard of that.
And we will also talk about an interesting
shift within the American military, the American
military.
Now, members of the military expected to vote
for Joe Biden over Donald Trump.
That is not the way things usually go in history
with the military vote.
So all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com.